[Music]
claudia is in orlando hi claudia welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for having me sure
what's up
um all right so my husband and i are on
baby step number two and we're planning
on relocating within the next year
we're debating if we should sell our
house now while the market is high and
rent until we decide where we're moving
to
or wait until we're ready to move but
risk the price of the house dipping
if we sell now we could make enough
profit to pay off our debts build an
emergency fund and have the 20 down
payment for our next home um but rental
around 500. you think you're going to
move in the next 12 months
i yes we will
okay no you don't need to worry about
the price the house dipping it's not
going to dip in 12 months
okay so you think that we should stay in
the house and then just wait until we're
ready to know yeah it might slow down
and be a little bit more difficult to
sell but the price the value will not go
down
all right so no i wouldn't i that's my
prediction now that's worth every dollar
you paid for it right
you know economists and weather
forecasters are the only ones that could
be wrong most of the time and keep their
job right
so
i'm not either one i'm not either one
but i did look at the weather app
earlier and um
so no i i honestly i mean i've been
doing real estate for 40 years
and i i've watched it a lot the number
of times that real estate prices went
down
in my lifetime is once
that was 2008. they've not gone down
okay now in certain neighborhoods they
might go down but that's a neighborhood
problem it's not an economy problem
okay now what is going what is going to
happen is interest rates continue to go
up and as some of these uh supply chain
and inflationary things smooth out
probably the price the rate of price
increase on houses is going to slow so
like last year in 2020
or 2021 we saw a 32 percent increase
in 22 we're projecting a seven percent
increase
in house prices so the the increase is
going to slow down but that's different
than it going down in value we do not we
don't have any indication the data we're
seeing at ramsey that's going to go down
in value so i would not go to the
trouble to sell it early get yourself go
through all this crap have to move oh
god and go rent for a year now all just
because you're afraid it's gonna go down
no
you can hear everyone who's shopping for
houses right now collectively grown
it's like oh man but
they're not going down yeah they're not
going down they're just not there's too
much of a shortage
there's i mean we still have way too
many buyers chasing too few sellers
right now it's still still that and
that's that's not going to subside
completely in one year and go the other
direction
i mean what would have to happen for
house prices to go down have to have a
complete inverse of where you are right
now i had to be 10 houses for sale for
every buyer
instead of 10 buyers for every seller
and that's not going to flip that
dramatically in one year it's just not
going to do it well for all the people
who just groaned i'm in i'm in there
with you we're currently in the market
for a house and can feel your pain but
yeah i guess that's the yeah
it's gonna go up it's gonna go up it's
just a matter of how much
and well and hopefully it will calm down
because this white hot
is not good for anybody no it's it makes
the sellers crazy it makes the buyers
crazy makes the real estate agents crazy
they were already crazy i mean it's just
it's crazy everywhere it's just it's no
fun